hi there steve kaufman here today i'm
going to talk to you about learning
french
french was my first love when it comes
to languages
there's an expression in french in fact
you always go back to your first loves
i love french i love all the languages
that i learned but i have a special
feeling of affection for french
i studied french at school i couldn't
speak at the age of 16 i went to mcgill
university had a professor who turned me
on he turned me on to french
civilization to learn a language you got
to really love the language be committed
to the language want to be part of that
community of people who speak that
language
that's what happened to me i got very
keen i ended up going to france for
three years where i studied uh political
science at lansd to detune politique in
paris
french is a precise language it's the
language of logic this was the world at
ciaspo all of our presentations had to
be presented uh premier party
part one here there's empathy on this
and that on the one hand this on the
other hand that everything had to be
presented in a very balanced way
the sort of cartesian
from decalt formula which i still use in
making presentations it was a good
training not only for my french but in
all languages learning to be more
i would say precise and logical in the
way you present your ideas not just
running them on although here i'm making
a presentation i'm just running them on
so
french was the language of of logic
and uh
i hardly recommend french but french has
some difficulties french is difficult to
understand
uh difficult to understand because
first of all it's fairly
monotonous people speak in monotones
it's not like english or swedish or
tonal languages
tends to roll along a fairly monotonous
range of tones
and also there's the nasal sounds and
then the way the sound of the
word is carried on to the next word
uh and so these are things you have to
get used to one thing i recommend
insofar as pronunciation is concerned is
to get used to making the sort of uh
sound
there's lots of uh and all and you kind
of have to pick up on that and have it
flow through your pronunciation but it's
also a bit of an obstacle
uh when you're listening and they also
slur words together as we do in all
languages instead of saying
set idea becomes study
and so forth so these are things you
have to get used to
uh
and you should get used to the whole
flavor of french you should become a
little more argumentative but in a nice
way
all this kind of stuff is part of the
font of being of being french or
pretending your french and really
getting into the language now i'm
getting a little ahead of myself here
as you know i recommend that
in order to learn a language you have to
first expose yourself to a lot of the
language a lot of listening and reading
and particularly in french where if you
come up with a few words uh phrases that
you can say uh je m'appelle my name is
steve my name is steve if you don't
understand what they're saying you're
lost so build up your comprehension
build up your vocabulary
it's relatively easy to do in french
because 60
or more of the words in english come
from norman french so you'll find a lot
of words that you will recognize even
though they are obviously pronounced
differently and they may mean different
things in french but this makes learning
the vocabulary a lot easier than you
know russian
but there's no point in trying to learn
all those what they call cognates those
words that are similar to learn them up
front you won't remember them you'll
come across them and you're listening
and reading but you'll just find that
it's easier to retain the vocabulary now
grammar
obviously the big bugbear in french is
the tenses
but there i feel with grammar you've got
to try to simplify
i have a series of grammar books at home
that i bought just for the fun of it
published by dover d-o-v-e-r you can
google and find them on the internet
none of them is longer than 100 pages
they're very short descriptions of the
grammar
that's the kind of book you need to have
so you can refer to the grammar from
time to time because in most grammars
there aren't that many issues in fact i
think there's probably
10 or so when i went to learn romanian i
made up
200 sentences in 20 different categories
i had someone
translate them and record them and i
listened to these patterns of all the
different key issues over and over again
to get used to how they say things
because the issue is how do they say
things in that language rather than
complicated grammar explanations or
terms that we can't deal with
although there are some terms that are
useful okay
sort of the fundamental 10 issues in any
language are the following in my view
one is
the issue of of how they make
statements positive statements negative
statements and questions so in french
it's je suis conta
content again i cognate okay happy just
i'm happy
i'm not happy
sandwich the verb you come across that
very early it seems strange at first
very very quickly get used to it
a question escutch
asks a question
or you can say etu content so there's
two ways of saying are you happy or
anything else for that matter so that's
point number one is how do you make
these positive neg or negative
statements or how do you ask a question
not necessarily in any order because
verbs are kind of key but you have to
get used to the what in english we call
the w words where when why
who
how come which
and most of those in french start with a
queue
or c combian
et
cetera so you get used to those
you can save them if you're in link
which i very much recommend you do
and if you save them a link of course
you get lots of examples and the
examples come
in two sections in link
either from our library
or from lessons you have already studied
the advantage of looking at examples
from lessons you have already studied is
that you probably know the words
very often if you're reading in a
grammar book
uh
you look at examples but you don't know
the words that's not so very helpful so
the w words
um
pronouns i think is another thing again
none of these things are you're going to
master up front you just get exposed to
them you start seeing how they perform
so you know the sort of this that these
and those words you know
uh
you need to get used to those or
pronouns you know
and how they deal with yours mine my to
me
these are the kinds of things
revolving around pronouns that you have
to get used to
another thing in french
gender and number there are languages
like japanese that have no gender no
number but in french they have both and
things like pronouns and
adjectives
uh they have to agree
and verbs even agree so those are what
do i mean by agree just because
i'm a male so it's just we can't tell
if it was a ella she
content we put an e at the end and
notice how the pronunciation changes
don't hear the t that's another thing by
the way that makes french difficult to
understand and difficult to read
because a lot of letters are not
pronounced je suis by the way s-u-i-s
sui s the second s isn't pronounced je
sweet
the last t isn't pronounced
but if it's ella and it's e-l-l-e so
this the second l and the second e are
kind of useless but
l-e-s-t e all you hear is a s and t
aren't pronounced el e contolt and
because there's an e at the end we hear
the t otherwise we don't
got to get used to it
uh it seems like an awful lot up front
as i say but these are things that you
can review over and over again
if you have a little grammar book
handy
uh
also because they have plural so nu
n o u s we don't hear the s new sum
if we're all male
we just hear it we put an s at the end
and we don't even hear it
but if it's
the girls
ella plural
still sounds the same but they've added
an s at the end
however
sometimes the letters at the end
that you can't hear
you do hear them
if they are added on if there's a vowel
starting the next word there's big thing
in french pronunciation is
uh
carrying on the sound to the next
uh word if it starts
with
a
vowel for example i said
i say premiere
so
again i'm just giving you an outline of
some of the things the joys of french
that you can look forward to
remember that everything that seems
strange and overwhelming at first and
i've experienced it in learning chinese
and russian and you name it you
eventually get used to if you give
yourself enough time with the language
all right now let's talk a bit about
verbs
very soon you'll discover that whereas
in english we say i go you go he goes
only that he go changes in french every
one of them changes
you just got to get used to it
very difficult to remember these
conjugations you can spend all kinds of
time pouring over conjugation tables
in my experience
it's a very
unsatisfying thing to do because you
forget them you might remember them for
tomorrow's test and then you forget them
so you constantly have to refer to them
and then you see them in context and
it's very easy nowadays if you're on the
computer you just google you know
conjugate
french conjugations or conjugate the
verb alle or whatever the same with true
with true by the way with pronouns
adjectives anything you want to look at
just google google and it'll be there
and of course uh there's a variety of
tenses in french i don't think their
tenses are more difficult than our
tenses are in english
uh but there are things there that you
have to learn and there's things like
the conditional which means like would
like i will is the future i will go
tomorrow i would go if so there's a
condition there i would go if and the
french you know instead of saying
like i will go they'll say
i would go if and you have to learn the
endings by regularly reviewing them in
tables seeing them in context and so
forth
that's the conditional the subjunctive
which is a bit of a bug bear in romance
languages
it all that means is that there are
certain expressions like
you have to go
i want you to go
although you went
uh etc
and there are other examples where the
verb has a different form and that's all
i will say here because you can read the
explanations and at first they won't
make sense but once you've seen them
often enough
the subjunctive will start to make sense
and slowly you'll develop the habit of
saying
using the subjunctive form of the verb
at the appropriate time
um
you know basically that's about it
relative clause like we say the house
which is on the hill la maison
uh
the house which we bought that's how
they form the relative clause you've got
to figure that out
there are some things that they do
differently like the french don't and
they are not hungry or cold they have
hunger and they have cold and there's a
few other things like that largely it's
a matter of getting used to it
for french therefore first of all it is
a lovely language
it is
i hate to say this but it's a bit of a
prestigious language there are countries
in europe particularly
and even now in asia where french is
considered to be a prestigious language
it's not surprising because we have to
remember that in the 17th and 18th
century
good part of the 19th century france was
one of the largest countries in terms of
population in the world
uh france was quite a bit larger than
russia in terms of people i don't
remember the numbers quite a bit larger
than britain and it was the dominant
culture dominant civilization
and there are so many goodies in french
civilization in terms of writers in
terms of painters in terms of simply
visiting france
paris or or in you know in the south of
france or in i don't know on sea and
there's a whole bunch of stuff there
that you can access so much better if
you speak french not to mention the fact
that french is spoken in other countries
like in canada it's spoken in eastern
canada in quebec and new brunswick it's
spoken in in many countries in africa
and not to mention belgium and
switzerland
so it's well worth the effort but don't
even though i went through very quickly
some of the issues of grammar
uh
you know the grammar can be a bit of a
stumbling block don't let it be get past
it go past the grammar enjoy listening
and reading build up your vocabulary
using link which i would recommend and
go back and visit the grammar from time
to time once you have some experience
with the language and you'll find that
gradually with enough exposure some of
these things start to become natural
there's a phone call so i'm going to
leave you thank you very much bye for
now